[Music]
this is a married couple on the
line oh boy let's go out to Mike Mike
Mike Mike Mike in Oklahoma what's up
dude I'm doing good how are you I don't
know man I just I see the line Jenna
gave me a line of what this call is
about and and then she just said oh yeah
his wife's on and I'm like oh this is
going to be okay and you're asking for
this right I'm asking for it oh geez
okay all right um so let's uh bring on
your wife terara cool yep yep let's
bring her on oh geez are youall in the
same house right now uh we're actually
uh outside my mother-in-law's House in
Colorado uh we're sitting in separate
cars right now so so y'all are having
this conversation at your
mother-in-law's house yeah all right
while I'm talking to her I want you to
download an app called hotels.com
because you may need it all right and I
have no affiliation with him I just know
they got lots of hotels all right let's
bring on Tara what's up t- money hey how
are you I'm probably better than y'all
are about to be what's
up uh no we knew we already knew what we
were getting ourselves into so I think
you're spot on with the intro oh boy all
right let's do this all right so Mike
I'm going to do something a little bit
different all right yeah okay so here
I'm just going to read
you what the by line is that Jenna has
put in my Monitor okay okay and then
I'll let you tell the story all right
and Tara and Mike is have you all talked
about everything are we sure we have
talked about everything all right here
we here we go let's dance so it says
underneath Mike from Edmund Oklahoma in
my Monitor it says wife and I have been
working through infidelity on my part
she's pregnant now struggling with our
I'm struggling mik struggling with our
lack of sex life is that correct correct
sure wish she wasn't on the phone all
right let's do this dude let's do it all
right walk me through it
Mike all right so um so basically our
story is um infidelity on my part uh
it's been two and a half years since our
since my confession uh we've been in
therapy air recovery groups we're part
of a very strong Community uh uh we
actually co-lead a marriage group of
other couples that are restoring their
marriages after infidelity and U and
pornography addiction um tera's actually
in her second trimester we had a
miscarriage back in May and basically um
yeah we're we're just struggling with
our sexual intimacy um after after the
infidelity after the miscarriage um and
actually feels selfish you know I feel
really selfish for even wanting to have
sex with her since she's not feeling
well during her pregnancy um this is
something we've talked about and we just
we uh we need help in this area so okay
cool so uh great job that was like you
really concise and you kind of put it
all out there so I'm proud of you um and
I saw heard a lot of reflection in there
it wasn't a lot of well this happened
and this happened you took a lot of
ownership there so that's awesome Tara
what's your what's your side of the
story um well that's we have done a lot
of work just like he said I mean we have
you know after something is Earth
shattering as infidelity um you have to
you have to start from ground zero and
that's what we've done I mean we have
literally I mean there was nothing left
after that and we have like you said
gone to years of therapy we still go we
have these accountability groups so the
the communication and the transparency
like we talk about everything like
there's no se you know so like we do
have like a really good foundation I
know we're only two and a half almost
three years into after infidelity but
we've made a lot of progress so my it's
just that like infidelity has I mean not
infidelity um like intimacy has always
been a challenge just his upbringing of
like you know abuse as a child starting
around five and then um you know
introduction to pornography starting at
5 so that's kind of where his journey
started and then mine was like the
opposite like I didn't have like touch
for my parents like hugs and kisses and
so I could just like live the rest of my
life and like not be touched probably
and totally fine so you could see how it
was like an explosion waiting to happen
when we got married right but yeah so we
just um we worked through the infidelity
and we continued to and then when we got
pregnant in May um and we lost that baby
I mean it was really really hard because
we never thought that we would be
married much less have another child and
then when we lost that baby um you know
it's it's really really hard and then
now that I'm pregnant again it's like
the trauma from like not only the trauma
from losing the baby like pregnancy
after loss is one thing but then you add
in um you know all the stuff with the
infidelity kind of came out once our
daughter was just born so there's kind
of like that impending like okay are we
going to do this again once we have
another baby and then there's the fear
of losing the baby and then I've just
been really really sick on top of it all
um so it's just like this like triple
edged sword it feels like I'm like if I
don't have sex with him like I might
throw up on you but you know it's like I
I don't it's like intimacy is it's you
know what I mean it's like a really big
deal for us because if we don't have
intimacy for months at a time like is he
going to spiral again back into this you
know this this hole that he's dug
himself out of so it's just like super
complex okay so it it's super complex
and we can pull some pretty clean
strings on it okay and level things out
a bit is that cool yeah um I know y'all
have both been to counseling I'm going
to bypass probably a year of therapy
okay and kind of cut to the some the
chase on some things just to make this
like that way it's not like a five hour
call um and I'd love it as y'all
continue I'd love to have you back on
almost recurring and we can kind of walk
through what this looks like if y'all
ever interested in that okay oh sure
yeah um yeah I'm
interested
so I'm getting to a place where I wrote
a whole book on trauma right and and and
where you go from here and the
importance of our childhood stories I
think those stories are really important
to peel back and uncover right
and I think the challenge remains is
whether I'm working with people in
marginalized communities I spent my
whole career doing that I don't talk
about that on the show because I I don't
want ever that I don't want other
people's marginalization to be how I
move my career forward right but I spent
20 years doing that I've sat with people
who lost everything everything I've sat
with people like you guys whose marriage
is an ash and you're deciding are we
going to do this or we going to like
whatever what are we doing next right
but every single time I've sat with
somebody and they're sitting in the
trauma we always land on this one core
question what are we going to do
now and two and a half almost three
years removed from the affair infidelity
right uh or multiple Affairs or whatever
it happened to
be I want to really challenge y'all to
to not go back to well when he was five
he experienced this and I didn't have
touch and so I experienced this because
where we are now is you both committed
to being in a marriage that's here right
now right right and so those stories
might play into why our nervous system
responds the way it does with those GPS
pins I talk about all the time right it
it might light me up or it might do this
or do this but every day I have a choice
as to what this day is going to look
like
period And I might have to practice for
as much as a decade to turn the corner
on some things but I am here now okay so
I want to I want to honor and know that
those past stories are there but I want
to spend the bulk of my energy in the
present moving forward is that cool does
that make sense yeah yeah definitely
okay so in in real quick terms
when you're like h i don't want sex I
don't want to be touched like I don't
feel good I haven't gone to the bathroom
in eight weeks and I feel like I'm going
throw up every day and oh my gosh and I
just feel all bloaty and gross and my
parents didn't even I want that part to
be
done does that make sense I want to live
where we are right now because here's
why when we live in the right now you
have to take ownership of what happens
next it can't go back to well they did
this and that goes the same for you too
Mike like it's not weird you're not
broken and I'm applaud you for saying it
out loud I want to have sex with my wife
a
lot and I would prefer to have sex and
her not barf on
me that makes it weird right yeah and we
don't talk about this enough men don't
talk about this enough I don't know that
I don't know many guys um outside of
some sort of pathology who wants to have
what I would call duty sex or chore
sex right like here she is just get
getting off sex like well she's sick and
grow and feeling gross and pregnant but
she's gonna take one for the team like I
don't know many guys who enjoy that no
right here here so Mike here's what I
want to get at with you and I'm sure
you've been through some of this with
counseling and I'm gonna man I could do
a whole
five five week episode five weeks of
this on the show men have been funneled
into this world where sex is the only
form of intimacy that is acceptable it's
okay it's the only tool we have and you
compile you you stack that on top of
your childhood which your nervous system
was wired with pornography into it like
um Sensational sex performed by
professionals right right that's how
you're you grew up and you have
childhood abuse sexual abuse or physical
abuse what what did you experience as a
kid yeah um just a lot of uh other just
other kids around my age just a little
bit older um pretty much making me
engage in sexual acts with other kids
there you go okay all right surprisingly
common and surprisingly frustrating and
disturbing right so both all at the same
time can I go one step deeper with you
both on the phone yep yeah okay please
Mike
sometimes the layer beneath the I want
to have sex is I don't really I love I
love deeply I would die for but I don't
like my
wife I don't like her conversations I
don't like the interactions I don't like
how she's always complaining about me I
don't like that she doesn't desire me
the same way I desire
her and pornography solves that problem
instantly a woman at work who laughs at
my jokes and only sees a curated version
of myself who thinks my text emojis are
hilarious that works until it blows up
everything right or here's another one
right Mike has created a world how long
have you'all been married eight years
eight years how many kids one one okay
Mike has a world where he's got a a one
child didn't really understand the depth
and gravity and feelings and emotions
around a miscarriage I talk to Men Who
feel it as deep or deeper than their
wives and then I talk to men who are
like I don't get it like my wife is
sobbing and I don't know what to do and
everything I do is wrong because it's
not bothering me the same right and
because everybody Grieves different and
what you do to control yourself during
those seasons is you just shut the
machine
down you build a life where you feel
completely
dead you go to autopilot and autopilot
keeps you off pornography autopilot
keeps you out of another affair
autopilot also keeps you out of trouble
because you're not saying the right
things after a miscarriage autopilot
keeps you out of I don't really
understand what this little kid running
around here doing and I just know that
my wife's telling me I'm doing it wrong
all the
time
okay and so we create a world where sex
is the only time we feel
alive that's it it's the only time I can
get my heart rate up past you know 75
beats a minute as if I'm having
sex and so here's why I tell you that a
lot of the conversations about I want to
have sex I want to have sex I want to
have sex have to do with the life we've
created for
ourselves okay and sex everything my
feeling alive getting my heartbeat up I
don't have any hobbies I feel like I'm
failing at my house I feel like I don't
like my wife I feel like she doesn't
like me all of that gets dumped down one
slide on a on a on a water slide at a
water park and it's well let's just do
it let's just have
sex and and if I can increasingly push
the boundaries while we're having sex
and go to this position or this thing or
this weird after eight years you kind of
start pushing the boundaries on most
everything we've tried it or we've
thought about it or I'm trying to get
her to read my mind and do some things
that she like what right all of it
right and then you have that one person
that you run into and she already knows
all and she brings it up and you're like
oh my right so these things happen
supernaturally I mean not supernaturally
like Superman but like it's just just a
natural progression here what I want
youall to begin to ask yourself is what
does our intimacy and desire look like
outside of having
sex have y'all heard me talk about the
gas pedals and
brakes um I don't think I have okay I
want y'all to order a book by Emily nski
called come as you are Co M as you are
the um the cover of the book you're
going to get it and go you can't be
serious
I'm serious that get that book and I
want youall to order it I want you to
read it together okay it's a book for
women about women's sexuality but it's
been incredibly instructive to men who
I've asked to read it myself included
here's where it's so important it talks
about the myth of a sex drive it's not
real it's not a thing we've been taught
that women have sex drive light to men
it's not
true sex and intimacy is this series of
gas pedals and break
what does that mean that means I want to
create a world where there are as few
breaks as possible and as many slammed
on gas pedals as
possible Mike it may stun you to find
out that a dishes in the sink are a
break to your wife she doesn't know why
you don't know why you just know that
when you're like hey let's have sex
let's have sex she's like well I got to
go clean the kitchen you hear that as
she would rather have a clean kitchen
than be with
me yeah right yeah what she's dealing
with is 200 years of feminine baggage
about what your house is supposed to
look like if you actually love your
husband and so for her I can't even be
in the moment knowing that I'm failing
him out there in the kitchen with her
with dishes in the sink or I'm making
that up I'm just inventing that right
right I cannot have sex with you until
bedtime is done perfectly
and you're thinking we just lock the
door let's party
right yeah and so what I've seen um Dr
nagi's book is is extraordinary but what
I've seen and heard all across the
country is couples backing out of the
bedroom
conversation and by the way there is a
moment we got to put sex on the calendar
we have to um can we hold hands one
night can we do the um John delone
erotic envelope system um where you put
five things in an envelope and she puts
five things in an envelope and we just
commit over the next month we're going
to pull one of these things out a week
or one of these things out twice a week
or one of these things out every two
weeks and one of them may just be
holding hands and Mike You're Gonna Go
son of a
right and it might be in the morning you
pull it out and Tara it's
um Regular boring married sex then you
know okay Mike here's what here's all
the breaks I've got going for me
mhm laundry the dishes the this the that
the thought of
you um looking at pornography again our
Netflix history which I stumbled on and
saw that you were watching
whatever these are all breakes for me
and Mike goes cool I got it what else
right so we're GNA have the brakes and
gas pedals conversation in gas pedals
what are the things that turn me
on what are the things that turned me on
I don't want to get too detailed into my
house but last night I clean the kitchen
up I put all of the rags like the dirty
rags I put them in the washer and washed
and dried
them and I emptied the dishwasher after
the after stuff was done I cleaned it I
just went around and and it wasn't to
try to have sex it was I now know what
my wife walks in the door and she her
shoulders drop and she's like ah
amazing see what I'm saying we're
creating a world and and her vice versa
with me uh um here's the last thing Mike
you're not broken for wanting
sex while you're married you're just
not and terara your body is not yours
anymore you share it and how old's your
little
one uh our daughter just turned four oh
my gosh yeah yeah so your body's a
jungle gym and it has been for the last
four years yeah yeah you're dealing with
pregnancy loss yeah you're having that
everyday every every time you have gas
every time your heartbeat accelerates a
little bit every time you get a weird
movement you're like oh is this it is
this it is this it right am I right yeah
okay yeah you Mike you don't understand
how much Tara is not breathing during
the day holding her breath absolutely
right absolutely and
Tara we we could talk about sex I don't
think you know how much Mike loves
you yeah in a crazy way and I think the
only way Mike has been given permission
by himself and his upbringing in his
culture is I can demonstrate that by
having sex with you or going and make a
lot of
money yeah and would would I be right to
say Tara there's a whole bunch of other
things that serve as breaks in your mind
and in
reality oh yeah can you give me two of
them real quick uh I mean you were spot
on I was laughing when you were talking
about like dishes and like like
literally like the dog's bowl being
filled up with food you know just like
the smallest things
I know it sounds crazy but it's just
like one less thing I have to do and
worry about so you were just spoton with
all of the breaks you were talking about
like I I resonate with those so I want
you guys to go out and have a date and I
want you to spend a week thinking about
here are the things that really turn me
on and here are the things not that turn
me off like bad breath or right you're
like you haven't showered not like that
turn me off but prohibit me keep me from
getting in the mood okay okay and I want
youall to write those down and what
you're going to do is give each other a
road map to each
other okay and that's a different than
hey can we have can we like start with
oral sex and then go to regular sex and
then move that's that's that's
peripheral you'll get to those spots but
before that what if we created a world
that I walk in my shoulders drop and
then we can say are you up for it
tonight you want to party and she's like
I'll party or
we can party but I'm gonna barf on you
and Mike is like that's a risk I'm
willing to take right
right but Tara imagine a world where you
go to put your four-year-old down and
you get done singing the song and you
come out and the dish are taking care of
and the dog's taken care of and Mike the
whole time you're like I've been working
all day bust I who gives a crap this is
about creating a world for your
wife and Mike you're honest about
here's the things that turn me on a text
message in the morning a morning
hug uh sexy text messages throughout the
day uh and maybe Tera you got to put
text reminders on your calendar whatever
I don't whatever it is but let's let's
work through creating a world outside of
the
bedroom and I've just heard it over and
over and over and over and over that
often the bedroom issues begin to Magic
Ally not magically very practically
transform
themselves we'll link to the book in the
show notes but I want you two guys to
pick it up today buy at your Christmas
present to yourselves read that book all
the way through and it's going to be eye
opening for you Tara who grew up in a no
touch no discussion home and Mike you
are going to get a Humanity behind the
pornography that you consumed since you
were five in a way that you probably
have never imagined never imagined go
check it out thank you all for calling
hey call back anytime I'd love to have
y'all on if yall try this out you'll
have the breaks and gas pedal
conversation and it fails spectacularly
call me back and have me on and and I'll
have you on the show and we'll talk
through it or if it starts working and
slowly leaning in the right direction
I'd love to have that conversation too
and we can get more more concrete
examples about sex we can go on whatever
Avenue you want to go to but I love that
youall are having the question and man
talk about an amazing example of what
life after infidelity can look like two
people who said let's rebuild the whole
thing from the floor
up